mountaineering is dangerous that's why
we suggest getting proper training help
a colleague out with the Black Diamond
sideboard crampons it's the most
dangerous object in the offices moment
these crampons feature eight secondary
spikes and two hooded front points that
you can adjust first attach and adjust
the crampons to fit your shoes you're
going to want make sure they fit
securely by first shaking them and then
kick testing then make sure you test the
front point angles first before you
climb let it go when it feels right go
for it
just make sure when you get to the top
you choose your first step down very
carefully